ما حقيقه ان الاجهزه الفلسطينيه تتحرك في
مخيمات الضفه لمنع هجمات مسلحه ضد الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعني اولا هذا ما يقول
الاسرائيليين لكن على ارض الواقع السلطه
نفسها لا تريد او لا ترغب في ان ترى صداما
كبيرا في الضفه الغربيه مع الاسرائيليين
وبالتالي هي عملت منذ زمن بعيد منذ انطلاق
الفدائيين الجدد في فلسطين هنا في الضفه
الغربيه وكان مقرهم رئيسي جنين ثم نابلس
ثم طول الكرم ثم مخيمات الشمال وبعد ذلك
امتدت على كل الوطن الفلسطيني على الضفه
الغربيه بشكل عام وبالتالي لجات السلطه
بشكل دائم الى عدم يعني توسع هذه هذه
المواجهات مع الاسرائيليين من خلال اولا
يعني فرض عدد كبير من القيود تحديدا زادت
هذه القيود بعد 7 اكتوبر من خلال قضايا
كثيره يعني اهمها واولها هو قضيه يعني
التعليم الالكتروني او عن بعد هذا اولا في
الجامعات الفلسطينيه ثم بعد ذلك ايضا قضيه
يعني بعض الاعتقالات هنا وهناك تحت باب هو
انا اسميه اعتقال سياسي وهم يطلقوا عليه
انه يذهبوا بهم الى المحاكم من اجل تشكيل
لوائح اتهام وغيرها من الامور بالاضافه
الى الاجراءات الاخرى التي لا تريد هذه
السلطه ان ان يكون هناك انتفاضه جديده في
في الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي هذه جزء من
الاجراءات التي تتخذها لكن اي محاصره
المخيمات لا اعتقد ان السلطه حتى لو رغبت
هي غير قادره على محاصره هذهه المخيمات
ومنع العمل الفدائي اللي ينمو يوما بعد
يوم في الضفه الغربيه وهذا الكلام نراه في
كل يعني كل يوم هناك اجتياحات واقتحامات
للمخيمات الفلسطينيه تحديدا في شمال الضفه
الغربيه في طول كرم في مخيم نور شمس مخيم
طول كرم ايضا مخيم جنين وفي عقبه جبر وفي
الفارعه هذا اليوم وقبلها في كل المخيمات
وبالتالي الفدائيين هؤلاء يقاوموا هذا
الاحتلال ويوقع و بخسائر احيانا ويتم
استخدام لاول مره ل مره يعني الطائرات
المسيره في ضرب هؤلاء المقاومين
الفلسطينيين في اماكن تمركزهم او خ في
وجودهم داخل هذه المخيمات يعني عندما تقول
بانه بان السلطه لا تريد ان ترى صداما
كبيرا
واتخذت العديد من الاجراءات لمنع هذا
الصدام الكبير مع قوات الاحتلال هذا يعني
بانها لو يعني استنادا الى ما قلته انها
لو ام كنها التحرك لمنع هجمات ضد
الاسرائيليين في مخيمات الضفه لن تقصر في
ذلك انا بعتقد هذا كان توجه عام منذ اكثر
من عام او عام ونصف تقريبا عندما كان هناك
في اتفاقات وقعت او تفاهمات وقعت سواء في
العقبه او في سرم الشيخ تحت عنوان التهدئه
تحت الضغط الامريكي والاسرائيلي ايضا لكن
الاسرائيليين لم يلتزموا ولا مره بهذه
الاتفاقات وبالتالي هم نقضوه وهم يريدوا
ان اجتث حاله المقاومه الموجوده في الضفه
الغربيه حتى لا يتحول هذا النموذج الى
نموذج اخر مثل نموذج غزي وبالتالي يصعب
التعاطي معها وتعاون معها ومع ذلك منذ
اكثر من عامين ونصف قلنا انه هذه
الاجتياحات مستمره وهذه الملاحقات مستمره
على امل اجتثاث المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
تنمو وتمتد وبالتالي هم فشلوا في ذلك وبعد
7 اكتوبر انا بعتقد زادت ه زادت هذه
الكتائب زاد ايضا الفاف الحاضن الشعبيه
وحول هذه المقاومه وبالتالي صعب على
الاسرائيليين وعلى حتى السلطه الفلسطينيه
حتى لو رغبوا في ذلك ان يصنعوا شيئا لهذه
المقاومه الممتز اذا كانت اسرائيل سيد حسن
اذا كانت اسرائيل قد نقضت كل هذه
الاتفاقات فلماذا
تصر السلطه على تطبيقها لابل
التشدد بها امنيا بعد 7
اكتوبر يعني هم يبدو انه بعض قياده السلطه
لديها رؤيه مختلفه عن رؤيه الشعب
الفلسطيني اولا المقاومه عزلت هذه السلطه
السلطه عزلت نفسها بنفسها باعتبارها اصبحت
وكانها وكانها طرف محايد فيما يجري في
قطاع غزه تتحدث عن اغاثات تتحدث عن هدن
تتحدث عن علاقات دوليه الى اخره بالاضافه
الى زيارات المكوكيه التي يقوم بها عدد
كبير من المسؤولين الامريكان تحت باب
تاهيل هذه السلطه واصلاح هذه السلطه اللي
تصبح يعني ممكن باليوم التالي ان تذهب الى
قطاع غزه وتحكم قطاع غزه كما كان في
السابق في اطار انه السلطه الفلسطينيه
مسؤوله عن الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه والقدس
ايضا لكن يعني هذه الوعود التي تقدم
للسلطه تغريهم احيانا بانه في امكانيه
لعوده هذه السلطه مره اخرى الى قوتها
بالرغم انه شعبيه هذه السلطه في هذه
الايام انا بقول تنخفض ب تدريجيا وبعتقد
انه الامور بالنسبه للسلطه نفسها
ورهاناتها على الامريكان وعلى انه هناك
تسويات وان هناك يعني وعودا ستقدم لها او
تعطى لها هذا الامر انا بعتقد لم يعد
ممكنا او موجودا على الاقل في عند الشعب
الفلسطيني بشكل عام الا ان البعض ما زال
يصر بامكان ذلك وسمعنا قبل ذلك تصريحات
كثيره من بعض رموز هذه اله لكن للاسف
الشديد هذه التصريحات كلها لم تلقى صدا
عند المواطن الفلسطيني وانما كانت مرفوضه
جمله وتفصيلا بحيث ان البعض تراجع عن
تصريحاته التي قال عنها والشعب الفلسطيني
هو الذي يح بالنهايه كل من يخذل هذه
المقاومه وراينا المثل كبير عندما في
الاسبوع الماضي عندما ذهب احد هؤلاء الذين
ارادوا ان يحاسب المقاومه الى المسجد خرج
كل المصلين من المسجد لانهم هم الذين
حاسبوا هؤلاء الذين تحدثوا بهذه الطريقه
وبالتالي الشعب فلسطيني في واد والمقاومه
ايضا تتصاعد والسلطه الفلسطينيه للاسف في
واد اخر على اعتبار انه كل الاجراءات
المتخذ كان قضيه الاضرابات العامه حسن
خريشه نائب رئيس المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني من طول كرم شكرا جزيلا لك